figure if I'm reviewing a religious
movie I'll wear a religious shirt made
sense to me
so risen is ultimately another story
about Jesus's crucifixion and
resurrection right there you're like if
there is one premise I have seen the
most in movies it's this one but it's
seen ultimately through a different
angle Joseph Fiennes plays this Roman
soldiers ultimately the right hand of
Pontius Pilate he's charged with making
sure Jesus's followers don't snatch his
body and kind of staged a whole
resurrection thing but as we would have
it Jesus's body disappears so now this
guy is on the hunt for a body which I
did like the fact this guy is like no
facts are facts seeing is believing
bodies don't just rise so ultimately
he's either going to find a dead body
and find out this is all staged or he
won't he's gonna see things that makes
him question everything he knows to be
real he's gonna have to accept the fact
that this body rose from the dead it's
gonna have to accept that which we feel
is real in here that's right he's gonna
have to accept the fact that zombies are
real but I'm serious note I did like the
fact that this was taken from that angle
I thought Joseph Fiennes did a good job
as tom felton with them this draco
malfoy which is funny his name is lucius
in this movie I'm like Oh Lucius Malfoy
we [ __ ] it's a prequel story but he's
the young go-getter know he's like I'm
gonna follow you anywhere so they're
ultimately on their hunt that's right
it's the fugitive but really no one on
the run is just looking for a body I did
like the budget some of these Bible
movies you're like this had zero budget
this one actually had production behind
it made it feel a little more real but
you know this guy's on a wild goose
chase because you know the end result
this movie isn't made by someone who's
like ham and atheist and I want to make
this movie that shows Jesus was not a
messiah so you know that Jesus is the
Messiah in this movie so you know he's
really looking for nothing so you're
just watching him go through the motions
and in that I wish they pushed the
envelope a little more on him being a
non-believer kind of like The Exorcism
of Emily Rose all the courtroom scenes
one slide presents the case and the
other side presents the case you're like
they're both really good cases in fact
the case against Emily Rose being
possessed is a pretty solid one I wish
they had done that all the way to the
end I wish this movie ended with no real
clear agenda or angle I wish it was just
like I have this guy doesn't have
answers neither do we but that was
actually really cool to see but in the
end they go the route and I feel like
this is almost spoiler territory
although they do talk about it in the
trail
I'm still going to give you a spoiler
warning you've been born at a point the
movie he comes face-to-face with Jesus
and he's like that's impossible I have
to question everything everything I
thought was real is actually not real
and it's all different for me now now
he's a believer because you see his
bleeding but it felt kind of cheap for
me it was really cool seeing this guy
going no fax or fax seeing is believing
he was ultimately on the level with the
rest of us a lot of times someone hears
from someone who hears from someone that
they saw some crazy miracle but in the
end I don't really personally see
miracles on a day-to-day basis so it's
hard for me to qualify that I felt
really relatable I was like yeah I kind
of get where you're coming from dude and
at a point he gets this in-your-face
answers like okay well I guess he's no
different than the other apostles who
all saw that stuff - it was really cool
having someone on the outside looking in
and in the end now he's on the in-crowd
and all right we're just gonna watching
it play out now now this is clearly the
religious movie that's the angle it's
going which I expected that they would
do doesn't change the fact that as a
movie I felt it would have been more
interesting if that hadn't happened but
in the end guys risen was actually an
interesting angle and an interesting
take on a very familiar story I enjoyed
the movie as a whole and I will say
risen was actually a good time to lock
the hall required right guys so risen
have you seen it what did you think
about it or what's your favorite movie
about Jesus there are a hundred of them
out there and you don't even have to be
a religious person who have watched a
possibly you had a very religious
grandma who's like you want to spend the
day with me watch this whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more